this is very interesting we have the
first
approval rating for president joe biden
it's 63 percent this is the highest
approval rating
at any time for any president
dating back 12 years to 2009
to find an approval rating for a
president
higher than joe biden's current approval
rating of 63 percent
you have to go all the way back to 2009
barack obama's first year in the white
house
when obama hit 69 percent approval
note that donald trump never got to even
50 approval even one time during his
entire presidency now there's a couple
different things going on here
there is such a dramatic shift in covid
policy which is one of the top
issues for most americans right now from
trump who couldn't have failed more
miserably to biden who's at least trying
and we'll see what degree of success he
has
i think covet explains a lot of the
shift to a high approval rating for joe
biden
in addition presidents often have their
best approval ratings at the very
beginning
before they've done things that their
political opponents can say are bad
or done things that are actually bad
george w bush was different in that way
george w bush's approval rating
skyrocketing
i think to 8 was it 88 um after 9 11
which was not um which which was a bit
of a ways in
months in uh to george w bush's
presidency but typically this is when
january february march of their first
term this is when presidents have their
highest approval so
it's not totally shocking that biden's
doing okay now the fact that he's at 63
is quite interesting we've not seen an
approval that high for a president in 12
years now being realistic biden
probably settles below 63
if he can really turn the pandemic
around in the next four to six months
maybe he could get to 68 maybe he could
get to 70. remember that right now
about 30 of this country is completely
whackadoo
okay and uh it's very hard for me to
imagine that biden's ceiling
is much higher than 70 or 72 percent
anyway
so maybe a successful biden can peak at
67 68 maybe 70 and
a successful biden would probably settle
somewhere around
the mid 50s if he does well if he does
as poorly as trump then you'd expect to
see him in the high
30s low 40s uh the way that donald trump
does the the real test for biden
will be these next three to six months
what happens with the virus what happens
with vaccination
we are up now up to a one and a quarter
million vaccinations a day which is
great
and what happens when unemployment
expires for a lot of people
there are some major tests coming for
joe biden but these early numbers
very very interesting to see and at
least to the degree that a
hyper-polarized
country can be united behind what a
president is doing
63 approval and 69 approval of covid so
far
in this first week it is significant to
pretend it's not would would be
dismissive of something that
is significant this is when you expect
to see presidents with some of their
higher approvals
let's check in again about this in four
to six weeks let's take a quick break
make sure you're following the show on
instagram at
davidpakmanshow and while you're there
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over thousand
masks to health care institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is free
on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
david pakman dot com slash mask the link
is under this video
and you can save 20 on everything in
their store when you use the coupon code
david